welcome to this video playing mata leão
FML salio from spain and that's what you
get for playing sephora you instantly
get the reversed Grand Prix yeah I
really don't never like that very much
yeah okay now this is actually quite a
quite an ok line for black looks kind of
weird but it is definitely okay if I am
I can try to keep the pawn but it is so
it is a very risky business queen bee
three isn't this some sort of a problem
okay it seems that it's not a problem at
least is very relaxed about it um okay
II for where are you going to f4 okay
I can also take him yeah I don't know
let's see okay is just putting this out
and I can play Knightly fire for example
but you can play rook e8 No ok let's try
to not lose the Queen it's kind of
dangerous
okay so he has grabbed them
ja he gets an F or a banana and I don't
know how bad it is b3 Bishop e3 might be
an idea difficult really difficult this
position he goes before I really get the
default square this is not so dangerous
maybe but I don't get my bishop out this
is why I try be three yet it looks a bit
weird for the queen but I don't really
see how we can trap it I always have a
five everything else fails like night c5
Queen a5 look before Queen 85 I don't
know those moves I think don't lead to
much yeah it's not great on a three but
I have to develop it somewhere and I
don't really want to take on d6 I just
want to put it out so I can actually
play the rook rook e1 e 494 that that's
not bad i think
now that's an interesting
huh
so he wants to go if I really really
really badly am ok my queen is not
directly attacked i can do this move
trying to prevent his eform maybe
getting rooked you one ask him what his
pieces are doing on the D file they are
very very difficult position I Queens my
queen still looks looks vulnerable but
at the moment I don't see what he's
doing about it now c5 was interesting
but I'm just trying to prevent before
like very mechanically okay now he wants
to take them but i always have 92 now
maybe start with this move i mean i
cannot cannot really be bad i believe
but take 92 yeah of course decided very
quickly
III 94 I think he's got this each idea
but it shouldn't be what really why is
this working now I don't believe it I
can take on d6 with rupiah now to also
make sure it to is not coming
I don't see a move really i mean ii too
i just take the Queen was checking this
nothing he has to move the Queen
somewhere and I'm just taking these six
with the rookie to Andrew P 1 I don't I
don't think there is something jack yeah
i can now i can also take with the rope
here Queen somewhere then take on d6 mmm
well I don't know the come on let's just
keep the porn on f 2 mm keep with
basically keeping the position closed
today I'm not opening it up maybe I
could have just taken but i will i will
get the bishop on d6 and then fire head
on the clock as well i can take it with
the night
yeah probably it's not mattering that
much i hope i'm sure you form now that
said sets not got them okay that's just
your pen take him take a sound that sets
i think pretty pretty straightforward
intending intending Queenie seven okay
taking it and Queenie some and the
bishop is not really having good squares
the specialty hive threat is very
substantial bishop f7 i can take 55 and
it's over
should be four maybe time warning well I
didn't see that more
check
can I go 97 or not oh man I probably
have screwed this up somewhat yes it's
still a win I mean I will when on time
that sets clear but I also want to have
a winning position after this game was a
pretty black for its eyes are very
straightforward thing actually am I was
a little bit screwing it up when I was
basically sure of winning on time as it
sometimes happens yeah here I don't know
it looks it looks really risky because i
don't have not fully developed and and
everything looks a little bit if he can
be three we have six he could have
played before this is what stockfish is
giving with a chat very good game from
black now you will play see five of c5h
mmm that is good from black the am I
development is not good this queen bee
three business was probably not not that
brilliant and here rook da it was okay
for him yeah here it really was this III
move I guess I mean yet it's already a
not so great because I will just take
you for with a with a strategic
advantage but this was really check
basically losing a rogue f2 is better
but ok it's a win anyway I'm really just
appease up and it was it was okay up to
a certain point definitely
here Sergey two check check and now I
could just go ping g2 yeah that's very
simple hmm yeah this was this was what
what I was somehow missing a king g to
win said the F to pawn here in 97 would
have one now check I wasn't sure hey I
wasn't sure because I thought that maybe
I cannot prevent here i have this moved
aware he cannot go anywhere near and i
can take the porn okay yeah so this is a
screw it up a little bit but it's still
it's still winning here with all those
pawns okay wow that was a narrow one
thanks for watching